hi everyone I'm Jeff from the overwatch
team welcome to today's developer update
this one is particularly exciting for me
because we get to introduce you to
uprising the new overwatch event which
is now live so I want to talk a little
bit about why we decided to make this
event we listened to community feedback
a lot we really care what you guys have
to say and we've seen all the enthusiasm
for the previous events that we've run
like Halloween terror or winter
wonderland and we've seen a lot of
desire for a non real world related
holiday event so something that we came
up with kind of out of the blue there's
also been a big desire in the community
to hear more story behind overwatch and
then add to that we got such a favorable
response to junkin steins revenge that
people really enjoyed playing a little
bit more PvE or fighting ai-controlled
enemies that there was this great
convergence on the development team to
create this event called uprising so
little history behind the event what we
wanted to do was create something that
allowed us to take any moment from
overwatch history almost pulling out of
the Declassified overwatch archives and
saying here was a cool moment in
overwatch history we want to deliver it
to you and let you as a player you know
lived through it firsthand so what we
chose was a moment in overwatch history
that we call the golden era of overwatch
so in the overwatch timeline there was
the omni crisis when overwatch was
formed that was sort of 30 years before
the game that you guys know and play
every day took place then there were the
golden years that took place after the
ominous was resolved but when / watch
the organization was in its heyday and
then there was the fall of overwatch
which we talked a little bit about in
the 76 a teaser video that we showed so
this takes place in the golden era and
what's special about this event is that
it is tracers first mission
with over watch and you'll see what
we're putting out a comic along with
this and I encourage you all to read it
but you'll see at the time tracer sort
of in training but we're going to send a
crack team in to deal with the conflict
that's taking place in kings row and
that crack team is Reinhardt mercy and
tour yarn and they need somebody who's
familiar with the area and who better
than tracer to come in with them so this
this event will manifest itself in a
number of ways to you as a player one
there's a cool new loop box that has all
sorts of really great items not only
does it have the skins that the golden
era overwatch characters war so you'll
see the Reinhardt tour Bjorn mercy and
tracer skins but we also sort of
selectively pulled out some really cool
moments in overwatch history to make
skins for as well so you'll see Genji
and McCree's Black Watch skin or a
talent version of Widowmaker that we
think is really cool so there's some
good skins for you guys to enjoy the
loop boxes have a lot of other cool
stuff in there great animation and some
cool sprays and voice lines so hopefully
those are really appealing to you as
well and the thing that we're most
excited about are the two game modes
that we're adding to the arcade for this
so the main one is called uprising just
like the event and that's where you get
to step into one of these four
characters and play through this really
cool event that's all PvE it's much
longer than junk ensigns was so you'll
get to experience a lot more there's a
lot of story there there's some really
interesting other things going on like
Morrison and on Amar'e are sort of
giving you Direction over your comms so
hopefully that that gives you a little
bit more insight into what overwatch was
like back in the day as well and then
for the arcade again based on feedback
that we heard from you with junk ensigns
revenge we also are adding another card
to the arcade which is the exact same
brawl uprising but you could play with
any hero you want so you can pick any of
the 24 hero
ohs and tried all sorts of crazy
combinations to see you know hey it's
look how overpowered eva and zaria are
together or look at how challenging it
is if we do it with for dps and no
healers you know that could be a really
fun challenge for you so we heard a lot
of desire that after the junk ensign
event people wanted to play with
whatever hero they want and so we're
giving you sort of two versions the
intended version but also the super fun
you know play whoever you want version
there are achievements that some of them
apply to one of the cards and most of
them apply it to to the other cards so
there's achievement that you can unlock
and there are spray rewards for those as
well really you know at its core
overwatch was designed to be a pvp game
and we really believe in that six versus
six you know player versus player
team-based action shooter that's what
the game was designed to be but we had
so much fun making junk ensigns revenge
and your response to it was so so
overwhelmingly positive and a lot of us
have worked on PVE games before like
World of Warcraft or the starcraft
campaign that it was just so much fun
for us to try to branch out and do
something a little bit different so we
hope you not only enjoy all the story
elements that exist in the uprising
event but also the new gameplay that
hadn't really existed in any other form
and overwatch to date so we hope you
have as much fun with uprising when it
comes to playing it as we did with
making it and again thanks for all the
feedback that led us here in the first
place have fun with it
you